a las vegas homeowner says he was
seconds away from taking another man's
life after that man busted into his home
yeah brian the alleged home invasion was
caught on video and it's footage that
you'll only see on 8 news now
the homeowner says he's upset about what
unfolded in the criminal case
the i-team's vanessa murphy has this
exclusive story
just one shot so far the evening of
march 22nd
started off as peaceful for stephen
[Applause]
the costillonette i was sitting in my
kitchen i was watching the golden
knights
and i look at the clock it's ten to
eight but then he heard a boom
i mean it startled me i jumped while he
was inside his surveillance camera
caught what was going on
outside i mean i jumped i thought a car
hit the house and then again
you know when i heard the second one is
when i grabbed the gun i realized that
somebody's kicking my front door
the third time that's when he kicked the
door he says he was then
face to face with the intruder he was
staring right through me like i wasn't
there i'm literally standing there
like this gun two inches from his head
screaming at him please leave
i told him i'm gonna count to three when
i said one he just stood there when i
said two
i was shaking uncontrollably because i
knew
the next three i was going to pull the
trigger but that's when castile says the
man
left i thought it was going to kill the
guy and it's a horrible feeling
i didn't want to kill him he says metro
police responded quickly
according to this arrest report
detectives linked the suspect to a sober
living house
less than a mile from castile's downtown
las vegas home
a supervisor there said tyler milovadov
hadn't shown up for a few days
the day after the incident at castile's
home malavadov was taken into custody on
a home invasion charge
the day after his arrest court documents
reveal
he was granted bail i'd like to see an
ankle bracelet on him or
be evaluated mentally something that i
know he's not going to come back
according to this las vegas justice
court record pro-jam judge
justin zarconi ordered malavadov could
be released on his own recognizance with
intensive supervision
he must stay out of trouble and stay
away from castile's home
i wish they would be in that situation
and see how they feel i want to see how
they go to sleep at night now they gave
me my address and when the sun goes down
i'm literally jumpy in my own home
detectives say when they asked malavadav
why he busted into castile's home he
stated
the voices in his head told him to be a
daredevil
what about when the devil tells him to
kill me vanessa murphy 8 news now
the clark county district attorney's
office objected to malavida being
released on his own recognizance
prosecutors point to a prior felony
conviction
and says he scored moderate on a risk
assessment not low
the i-team also reached out to the las
vegas justice court a spokeswoman
says the court has no comment regarding
this case